well now we're heading to Kenya where
three Americans were killed in an attack
on an anti-terrorist base in the
southern coastal region Islamic
militants stormed the manda Bay airfield
in the country's lamu region on Sunday a
base used by US and Kenyan forces these
pictures which are currently looking at
they purport to show the fiery aftermath
authorities saying that five attackers
were also killed in the first assault by
the al-shabaab group on US forces in
Kenya @ed now to Nairobi to hear from
Marathi mu tiga of the non-governmental
organization the International Crisis
Group
why did al-shabaab target this
particular base in southern Kenya do you
think well as you mentioned in your
intro this is a very significant attack
it's the first time al-shabaab --is
struck at a foreign military base
outside Somalia and the fact that they
were able to infiltrate such an
important and psychologically
significant base is is very noteworthy I
think their messages were primarily
aimed at their domestic audience
al-shabaab has consistently tried to
show that it is still relevant it is
still powerful but it could also have
been aimed at hosting everything of
American engagement in south-central
Somalia over the past two years has been
very significantly stepped up drone
attacks against al-shabaab militants and
this would have been Singh are striking
against the Americans okay so you say
that it is an attempt to show that they
are still powerful in the region but you
know what is their level of strength at
the moment the fortunes of al-shabaab of
what and wind over the last decade in
2011 it appeared they were on the
backfoot
they lost control of major urban centres
including Mogadishu and the coastal city
of Kismayo but they have adapted and
showed remarkable resilience now we see
that they're able still to extort and
across Somalia they're able to attack
Mogadishu with near impunity and with
this attack they demonstrate a continued
capacity to stage assaults outside
Somalia so I would say that al-shabaab
remains a formidable force and it draws
primarily from the continued dysfunction
in Somalia put this attack into context
to us for us what does it have on Kenya
for example the coastal island of lambu
is a very important place for Kenya it
is a historical cultural center and
listed by UNESCO it rose in quite
significant numbers of tourists although
attacks are quite common around 2014 and
2015 there have been much fewer attacks
in recent years this obviously was aimed
not at civilians but at the military but
there will be concerns that this might
affect the tourism industry but also it
will force a rethink of government
policy on security there will be
questions on how militants were able to
access such a site more at emu tiga from
the International Crisis Group in
Nairobi thank you